las vegas original arts and crafts show
is back the harvest festival who is
sponsoring this next segment is here
with us today and they're back this
weekend the brand new expo at the world
market brenda thank you so much for
joining us oh my goodness it's so great
to be here it's harvest festival time
it's harvest festival time tell everyone
about it who's never been to harvest
festival we took off last year we are
back bigger than ever what can everyone
expect well we are the biggest we are
the most unique and it is a show that
has been traveling the western united
states for 47 years 37 of those in las
vegas so you're just not going to want
to miss it it's like a magical
marketplace you go in and there's all
kinds of artisans and crafters and candy
and potpourri and everything you're
going to want for one-stop shopping for
the holidays you shop till you drop
literally
indoors which is great so don't worry
about the heat
parking oh we have just the best news we
are in our brand new location we are at
the expo at world market center and uh
we have lots and lots of free cupboard
parking just take an elevator go right
into the hall it's convenient it's cool
and you're not going to want to miss it
i yeah i certainly don't want to miss it
now uh talk to me about there's i know
there's a charity tiger you're always
giving back to our community what's the
charity titles festival really believes
in being community responsible so for
over 20 years we have supported safe
nest and we filled their pantry up for a
whole year they really missed it last
year so we need everybody to pitch in
and bring non-perishables canned food
hygiene products and when you bring it
to safeness that will be right outside
the box office they'll give you a coupon
for two dollars off so let's get
together and fill their pantry up once
again you're saving money and helping
out a great cause as well now uh al
you're one of the vendors out there tell
me more about your company that's gonna
be out there well we make a trivet hot
pad okay that opens into a basket right
now it's opened
if we close it down you can take a hot
pot off the stove wow out of the oven up
to 500 degrees wow right on there and
you this is something you hand make yes
wow yes and that's what i love about
harvest festival people like al are
going to be out there who i mean you
made this with your own hands uh these
are local you're a local person in las
vegas local residents selling their
goods it's such a cool event yeah
american arts and crafts at its finest
we actually are a juried show so
everyone in our show
has been juried and everything is
handcrafted and handmade and so it
starts tomorrow though right it does at
10 o'clock friday saturday and sunday
one ticket for the whole weekend kids 12
and under free great kid zone strolling
entertainment we'll see you there oh i'm
going to be out there absolutely so just
real quick on the kidzone what's
happening in the kidzone oh we have cal
portland that's doing this great
environmental family
maze we have we have make it and take a
crafts but because of the way things are
we also have take it and make it so if
you want to stop by you don't want your
kids sitting down for too long of a time
we'll be handing you things so that you
can do all kinds of harvest festival
crafts at home and you mentioned too
there's traveling entertainment we have
strolling entertainment and so it will
be very festive and and just add to the
mood of our harvest festival original
art craft show marketplace brenda i've
known you since 1996 and every year
you're putting on huge amazing local
events and we love you for that thank
you so much well it's just so great to
see you and thank you for having us
please it's our pleasure las vegas
harvest festival original art and craft
show it's happening it starts tomorrow
the 10th through the 12th at the all new
expo at world market center bring a can
of non-expired food or paper products
for safeness and receive two dollars off
the price of admission rocky over to you